[Music]
I am so excited today because I am
joined by Lisette Olivera AKA Jess and
natural treasure edge of History which
is on Disney plus now how you doing
today I'm doing wonderful how are you
I'm doing great I'm so excited to talk
to you absolutely crush it in this show
so
my first question though I had for you
was people are going to see what the
character of Jess having a lot of
similarities to Ben Gates which I really
loved how did you go about and prep
those similarities while also keeping
Jess her own character great question
uh yeah so it's no secret Jess has a
computer brain like Ben Gates
um she operates on her own beat and I
think it's really special to see how
um she takes the analytical part but
also incorporates a bit more heart um
into how she discovers the the clues
um she has a lot of obviously personal
connection to the treasure like Ben
Gates does
um but I think for her she's constantly
toying with oh um should I listen to My
Heart in this moment and what my heart
says is wise to do or should I listen to
my head in the moment that's more
analytical and something that will help
further you know my curiosity
um so I think that's the difference
between her and Ben
um and yeah I think it's really special
how she kind of thinks with her heart as
well it's pretty cool yeah I love that
answer and you definitely bring that to
the character with the heart which is
great and I'm wondering speaking of Ben
Gates did you feel a lot of pressure now
being the torch carrier of this
franchise now like this big shoes to
fill of Nick Cage you feel that you know
I truthfully was just really excited to
just jump into it
um I already knew the series has the
same creators behind
um the show they are the same Minds
behind the first movie the second movie
and they had
um their intentions set out to create a
story from a different American
perspective 15 years later it is a
continuation so I knew that you know I
was hoping too that most most characters
from the movies would come back and um I
was really it was a delightful
experience to get to connect the worlds
officially in the show yeah for sure and
I love that answer too and how Fresh The
Show still feels which is great was
there any just with your craft because
you're so good at this is there any
other actors or actresses you admired
growing up or Draw from today currently
well I mean working with Catherine Zita
Jones was a huge inspiration for me I
learned so much from her I mean she
genuinely would was just a killer Billy
um she actually has such great charm
that I I started to fall in love with
her character a little bit and I was
like she's not wrong though I mean I'm
like actually maybe I kind of see her
point of view
um but you know besides her I've always
respected actresses that have had
longevity in their careers and take the
craft very seriously
um but also have a lot of range so you
know I look up to actresses like you
know Sandra Bullock or like Anne
Hathaway
um I absolutely love Viola Davis too I
think she has she's such a Powerhouse
um and Sandra Oh you know we love the
ogs I love it that's a great group my
last question for you when the just
Disney Plus profile icon comes is that
going to be the one you use on your
account oh my gosh I forgot that's going
to be a thing oh my gosh
yes I think that's going to be so
exciting actually I feel like I'm
probably gonna choose
um a different icon my whole family will
all be like just it's gonna be like a
Jess I like Ratatouille
um and then just just you know what I
mean I love that I love the two shout
out too um well he said thank you so
much for joining to me today everyone
check her out National Treasure edge of
History which is on Disney plus now I
will talk to you in the future